hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast learning biology from networks
and their structures i'm julia child of
lab birds and i'll be your moderator for
today's event we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
taking them into the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking in the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window try to answer as
many questions as we can you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems reading or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentations window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button in the lower left this webinar
has been improved for continuing
educational credit please click on the
continuing education credit button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credit Alamelu
8-inch introduce today's speaker john
patrick john magic received his PhD in
physics from the university of maryland
the station spoken to on the application
of complex network methods the
biological data sets with an emphasis on
understanding how errors an edge
identification effect net worth property
in conjunction with expensive training
he was a cancer research training femoh
at the National Cancer Institute working
to identify potential therapeutic
targets from a reconstructed gene
regulatory network in diffuse large
b-cell lymphoma in 2013 John started as
a postdoctoral fellow at the John
Quackenbush at dana-farber cancer
institute he is currently working on the
network inference and clustering methods
to better understand genetic and other
factors like drive phenotypes elementary
an orbit of John flat tape for his
presentation
thanks Julian so today I'd like to talk
about learning biology from networks in
their structure and what I hope to
convince you of is that when we
reconstruct or analyze networks and
biology that there is not necessarily a
priori an important feature set but
rather that we have to take that network
structure and think about it in the
context of the biological data that
we're using to make that network and so
the first half of the talk I'd like to
discuss understanding phenotypes using
eqtl networks and then the second half
of the talk will be about elucidating
drug response in tuberculosis with gene
regulatory networks so two very
different sort of multi own network
approaches the one thing that we will
see throughout those will use a method
called Condor to try to model this
biological regulation as a network
system so before I jump into the eqtl
networks briefly Condor stands for
complex network description of
regulators it's a method that we
developed here in the Quackenbush lab
and it takes as its input a bipartite
network which is just to say that you
have a network with two classes of nodes
the represented here as red squares and
circles and a network is bipartite if
you only ever have links between nodes
of different classes so where it's
where's only go to for blue circles and
our interpretation in sort of biological
context of this bipartite network is
that one class of nodes will be
regulators and the other class of nodes
will be the targets and in the first
half of the talk and you can PL networks
the snips will be our regulators and the
gene expression genes will be our
targets and in the second half of the
talk of tuberculosis gene regulatory
network the regulators will be
transcription factors and again the
targets will meet genes in their gene
expression so once you give Condor a
bipartite network what it does is then
clusters that network using a community
to structure detection algorithm and the
method for using that
that it uses under the hood is a
bipartite modularity maximization and
sort of simply put the goal is to
identify groups of nodes that have more
links within their community then that
you would expect by chance given the
degree distribution of that network and
so you can sort of formally assign a
quality function Q which is the
modularity and that's just the fraction
of network links inside a community then
then you subtract that based on the
fraction of link to it expect by chance
and so one of these modifications from
the more traditional modularity
maximization is that we use a modularity
show me sort of the second reference
here at the bottom where the fraction of
links expected by chance is altered to
account for the bipartite nature of the
network so we never expect that two
targets will share a link so once you've
done that once you've clustered your
network you can then look at the nodes
inside of those communities and I should
specify that each node goes into one and
only one community and every node is a
scientific and our intuition here for
identifying what we call community cores
is that not all nodes in the community
are equal in terms of their contribution
of the formation of that community
cluster so for example the node that
I've shown here with this green arrow is
connected to all four of the blue nodes
in its community in the center of
community and so it it seems to be very
important for the formation of that
community whereas the second node that
I've highlighted the second green arrow
on the right here is only connected to
two of the three nodes in its community
and so the intuition is that we'd like
to say that this first node is actually
much more important it's sort of in the
core of the community that it's harder
and so we can formalize that by
assigning it a core score which is a Qi
H so it's the chorus core four node I
and community H and it's simply just the
fraction of the match
larity contributed by note I and then
divided by the modularity of community H
which is the community that note on is
in so then what you can do is assign a
score to all of the nodes in your
network based on how central you think
they are to the communities that they're
in and then use that to ask whether or
not four nodes are more important in
terms of functional enrichment or
whatever it is that your biological
weapon ette work is trying to model so i
should also mention that Condor is
available as an r package on github and
feel free to email me if you have
questions about that there's a tutorial
available as well so our first
application of Condor was to
understanding genotype-phenotype
relationships with eqtl networks and the
intuition for for a sort of network
approach to eqtls is I think exemplified
by the following question and the paper
below it which is how many snips affect
complex traits so this is a nature
genetics paper from a couple of years
ago and they did you ah study looking at
253 thousand individuals and across this
huge population size they identified 697
variants that met genome-wide
significance for being associated with
height and the thing that I think is
particularly interesting is that they
found that if they use the top two
thousand thirty seven hundred or 9500
snips they are able to explain twenty
one percent twenty-four percent
twenty-nine percent of the phenotypic
variance so what that means is that as
we get larger and larger sample sizes
that are able to explain more and more
of the phenotypic variance we actually
need more and more snips to do this and
any one snip is not going to have a huge
explanatory power in terms of its
phenotypic variance so you know there
have been many calls recently for
collecting 10,000 samples to to
understand some complex disease cancer
what have you or maybe a hundred
thousand samples but I think the
question that that we need to answer is
what do we do with 9,500 snips that
explained a decent fraction of the
phenotypic variance but I can't go down
the hall and ask someone to make a mouse
model for all 9,500 snips and I
certainly can't have them start doing
that in combination where they pick
sniff one and step 100 and make a mouse
model for that so I think what there's a
need for is methods that essentially
embrace this complexity and this is
another another paper that came out
recently that I think exemplifies this
need as well this is a jiwa study with
three hundred and thirty-nine thousand
individuals and they show that the top
97 loose I account for two-point-seven
percent of the BMI variation and so even
the best hits only explain fractions the
very nation so this suggests that you
have many snips of weak effect that are
working together and so what we wanted
to do was design a method that embraced
this complexity at the outset we knew
that there would be lots of snips
working together so as we are a group
that likes to use networks are our
initial instinct was to use a network
approach to look for groups of snips
working together to try to influence
cellular function and so we did that by
using for the most immediate phenotype
in the cellular context which is to link
snips to gene expression via eqtl
analysis where eqtl analysis is just
essentially a linear association between
the snip genotype and the gene
expression of who gene you're interested
so then what we did is treat eqtls as a
network of links between snips and genes
which then gives us a bipartite network
so as I mentioned before the snips in
this case our regulators and the genes
are our targets and then the links that
we draw between them are from eqtl
analysis and those are the ones that are
you know I'll show in in next couple of
slides the ones that need an FDR of less
than ten percent so there's a great data
set actually for trying this method out
and that is the data released by the GTX
consortium so this is data from their
version six
and we looked at eqtls from 12 different
tissues there are 450 individuals
represented either 4900 samples and we
use the imputed genotypes and RNA seek
that they provided we did some basic
genotype filtering we kick we kept only
snips that had a minor allele frequency
greater than five percent across all of
the tissues since for each tissue has a
different number of genotyped
individuals and matching gene expression
so we made sure that we had a five
percent cut off for all and then we used
matrix eqtl which is a very powerful our
package for doing a cyst and transy QTL
mapping so our thinking was we wanted to
embrace all of the complexity of these
these associations so we looked at cysts
and trans together we then kept as links
in our bipartite network those eqtl
associations that had an FDR less than
ten percent so then we get our bipartite
network out we can run condor and
cluster these things and then we can ask
what sort of functional annotations do
we find in these clusters and I should
mention that one of the advantages to
embracing sort of a bipartite nature of
these things is that we get clusters
that have both snips and genes together
in the same community so you can
interrogate the genes in the community
ask with what is their enrichment their
role their functional annotation and
then you can switch and do the same
thing for the snooze so we ran on all 12
tissues Condor and did this bipartite
modularity maximization and so the
modularity values that we got out you
can see here and the modularity runs
between 0 and 1 or 0 implies that
there's no community structure and one
would imply sex like perfect community
structure and you can see that these
networks are highly modular with values
between point 75 and point 95 which is
fairly high if you look in the complex
networks literature and just to give you
a sense of how modular these networks
are what you're looking at here on right
is the entire network for brain each dot
in this figure represents a link and the
black links represent connections
between sniffs and genes that are in
different communities and we've arranged
this so that genes in the same community
are next to each other and snips and the
same community are next to each other
and then the colored links here
represent snips and genes that are in
the same community together so you can
see that there is a strong block line
structure here but then of course you
know this is a sort of a beautiful
network but does it have any interesting
biology so our first step for
interrogating that is to ask whether or
not any of the genes and easy QTL
communities are functionally enriched so
for all of the tissues and all of the
communities in each tissue we performed
a sort of basic fisher's exact go
enrichment using go stats package in our
and this is a heat map of the results so
each column is a particular community in
a given tissue and each row then is a
biological process from the gene
ontology and these have been clustered
beta based on minus log 10 for the p
value from the test that you got out and
so what we see are that even across
different tissues we find that
communities in these different tissues
cluster based on similar biological
processes that sense for example we have
skeletal muscle and the tibial artery
are have communities that are riched for
muscle development and contraction we
have a number of different tissues
including skin esophagus mokosa that are
enriched for epithelium development and
keratinization we find that cells that
have sort of high turnover fibroblast
and esophagus mucosa are enriched have
communities that are enriched for
mitosis and then something that was
interesting although not surprising if
you study eqtl literature is that we
actually found an adaptive immune
response community and enrichment for
that in all 12 tissues that
and then we also found a variety of go
terms related to the regulation of
transcription in eight of our different
communities and then sort of
reassuringly uh in one of our brain
communities we found enrichment fuller
nervous system development and synaptic
transmission and I should mention at
this point to that we did not feed any
prior biological knowledge into this we
just did a complete system trans eqtl
analysis we clustered the results of
that and then asked whether or not that
clustering was over represented for
biology so we didn't use any sort of
pathway annotations or anything to
filter of what we considered in so it
really is a data forward sort of
approach to models now one question you
might ask is whether or not these
communities simply just represent a
particular location on a given
chromosome and so what we did then this
is again this brain network that I
showed before this is a community too
that's blown up and what you're looking
at here is a circus plot or all of the
links in that community and the genes
are highlighted the red links that are
connecting across in this circus plot
represent links that are connected to
genes that contribute to this nervous
system development and synaptic
transmission and what you can see as
well as that this enrichment pulls genes
from a variety of different chromosomes
so this functional signal is not coming
from one specific location on the genome
but rather a multitude of different
chromosomes and that this eqtl analysis
seems to be pulling that together into a
community so as I mentioned before the
other advantage of looking at this
bipartite community structure approach
is that we can then interrogate the
snips so as a as a first pass or
question was where are the jiwa snips
from the nhgri gos catalogue so we
looked at the degree distribution for
all of the snips in our network which
are shown here in black
and you can see that they follow a ace a
very broad tail distribution probably
not exactly power law but certainly a
lot like and then if you look you can
see that there's a slight
over-representation in the middle of the
plot for the jiwa snips which are in
blue so you can see this they tend to
have a slightly higher frequency in this
intermediate degree distribution and so
the degree in this context for a snip is
just the number of genes that its
associated with in the eqtl analysis and
that's a little more clear here we're on
the y-axis we're plotting the observed
degree for the jiwa snips over what you
would expect it in degree distribution
and so what you can see here is that
there seems to be a cut-off past about a
degree of 10 and so what we're
interested in is given this enrichment
in this intermediate degree range are
these snips also likely to be cores the
G what's next so we plotted here eat
four scores for all of our Jia snips and
compare those to all of the non jiwa
snips and what you can see is that the
median for the duo snips is certainly
higher than for the non g wasps and the
p-value here you're looking at is for
the wilcoxon test so it looks like at
least in brain that our four scores are
are higher for the jewel ah sniffs than
for the non-gmo seems and they seem to
not be hubs with one potential outliner
and so if we look across all 12 tissues
we see a very consistent signal which is
that I you get this enrichment for
intermediate degree but you really don't
see any global hums it needs for the g
wasps snips even though we observe them
never so given this sort of signal in
the G wasps four-horse cores and since
we're using ostensibly healthy tissue
from the gtechs consortium what we
wanted to do was one asked whether or
not they have higher core scores which
we can see across different
different tissues here it's not true for
all 12 of our tissues but it does seem
to be true for many of them so for
example fibroblast esophagus mocoso lung
and breast artery to tibial in the order
and some of that may have to do with the
fact that we know the variation signal
from tissue the tissue may have to do
with the fact that we're using the NHGRI
jiwa sins but we're also interested in
looking at the functional annotation for
these course course names so what we did
is we pulled all of the data from
regulon DB which is a resource that
catalogs snips and then uses encode data
and the epigenome road map data to try
to categorize the putative functional
impact of a given snip and so we r e
categorize those slightly so that they
didn't depend on whether or not they
were in TTL since all of our snips and
these networks are already eqtls and so
this top category a is the one that has
the most confidence for sniffing
functional so it has transcription
factor binding as an from chip seek data
it has a matched transcription factor
motif for that finding site matched a
nice footprint and a DNA SP and then as
you go down there is less and less data
to support that I snip is functionally
relevant and so I here is no information
which just means that there was nothing
in regular DB for that snip however it
was a eqtl in our network so what we
wanted to ask was whether or not poor
scores were more likely to be
functionally annotated and so here on
the x-axis you're looking at the odds
ratio and on the y-axis you're looking
at these various categories and what you
can see is that certainly in brain there
appears to be a consistently positive
greater than one odds ratio for our poor
scores and you can see that for for some
of the ones that are less confident it's
really a function of
number of snips in the category so on
the right hand side you're looking at
the number of snips that were eqtls in
our network and we're also in the
category and on the left and regular TV
so this signal also seems to persist
across these other tissues so I'm
showing your number of examples this
brain is certainly one of the stronger
results fibroblasts as well long and
aorta also have have strong strong
positive signals for poor scores being
rich for functional annotation post
issues and one project that I should
list for this result is that regulon DB
Falls these things from encode so there
is going to be fibroblast we probably
have slightly more confidence in because
we have lots of those tissues in encode
and so there are force limitations to
using that database so this was a
reassuring for treating eqtl networks as
bipartite graphs seeing that we saw the
strong modular structure but we wanted
to apply this to a disease phenotype as
well to try to get a sense of whether or
not if you tell us something about
disease biology so we looked in COPD
which is chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease and COPD is the third leading
cause of death in the u.s. it's commonly
known by its sub types which are
emphysema and chronic bronchitis and
from a genetic standpoint one of the
things that's interesting about studying
COPD is that the environmental effect
that leads to this disease is fairly
well known and that cigarette smoke so
cigarette smoke especially in the United
States is the leading cause of COPD
however only twenty five percent of
smokers get COPD so we thought that this
eqtl network approach would be well
suited to studies so we pulled data from
the lung genomics research consortium
lgr see and that was a collection of
lung tissue from 163 individuals 126
cases with COPD and you can see their
distribution of disease severity in
in the rightmost column here which is
the gold stage which is a clinical mark
of disease severity and then we can
compare those to our controls and the
other thing that was nice here that we
we also had a smoking history for these
individuals so we did that we took these
hundred and sixty-three matched genotype
and gene expression samples and then did
the matrix eqtl approach looked at all
cysts and trans pulled them together
into a bipartite Network considered
everything with it in FDR less than ten
percent to be links in our network and
ran condor and then asked whether or not
the things that we're observing in the
gtex eqtl networks were similar so one
thing that we found that was was very
similar with the gtex tissues was that
the snip degree distribution seems to be
fat-tailed and in this case it may
actually be power-law distributed if you
consider the top 10 connected components
than their strong evidence that it is
power-law distributed however if you
include all of the links the probability
that it's a la distributed is out for
mate we did also observe that it was
again highly modular so you're looking
at the again at this sort of dot plot of
the community structure on the bottom
here and this this the plot above that
is just sort of a pretty visualization
where you can see that there are many
links within the communities and not
very many that are going between
different communities and the modularity
that we got was consistent with the
values that we saw in eqtl networks in
gtex with a modulator value of 178 and
we also found that if you live in the
bottom left here that NHGRI jiwa snips
also seem to be enriched for this sort
of intermediate debris range so the red
snips that you're looking at here are
the jiwa snips and then the black snips
the black dots gianyar are all snips in
the network in their degree but since
we're looking at COPD what we wanted to
do then was asked whether or not there
was a particular network feature for the
g wasps from
so what we did is working with
colleagues at Brigham Women's Hospital
who study COPD they recently published a
paper that's a meta-analysis that has
approximately 14,000 different in
approximately 14,000 individuals and
they did a Jewess for COPD we took that
and asked for all of the snips that were
in our network we computed a p-value
based area and FDR excuse me based on
all of the jiwa snips in our network and
reported p value and 30 of those had an
FDR less than five percent so then what
we asked was whether or not these snips
had any sort of particular features in
the network and the first thing we did
was look at the four scores and asked
whether or not they were higher for the
COPD jiwa snips compared to the non jiwa
snips in our network and we found that
the median core score for these 30 snips
was actually 20 times higher than the
median for the non significance nests
and another thing that we wanted to do
here was to test whether or not this
difference was a function of linkage
disequilibrium so you could imagine that
maybe love he sniffs OH and strong LD
and somehow that's driving the
connectivity of this network and driving
the four scores that were observing so
what we did is for our original
comparison here with FDR's significant
snips versus non uh we replaced our jiwa
snips with a matched set of 30 snip that
had the same LD structure as our jiwa
snips and we randomly sampled sets of 30
a thousand times and asked whether or
not this difference that we observed was
a result of heat of just the oldest
structure and so what you're looking at
on the right here is a histogram we use
the one-sided wilcoxon test the look at
this and the red dot in the bottom right
here is actually the true difference
between our jiwa snips and therefore
scores and non jiwa snips and then the
histogram here is just our firm muted
values and something I didn't show both
that we also tested is whether or not
this is a function of
distance to the nearest gene and we
found that that was not the case for
that as well again with the p-value less
than point 00 1000 rings so it seems
like this course core approach does a
good job of identifying on jiwa snips
what we found also is that the the
function for these 30 FDR significant
jiwa snips and copd were all annotated
with the exception 224 having putative
function and this is again coming from
regulan TV so the results that we saw in
the gtex eqtl network seem to be fairly
important with the same kinds of network
signal that we're seeing in our COPD
data set so just as a recap we see that
these eqtl networks really do show
strong community structure across
tissues and payment types these jiwa
snips from the nhgri eos catalog appear
to be depleted from global hubs however
the snips and the pores of their
communities are more likely to be
functionally annotated and they are also
more likely to be disease-associated so
switching gears here I'd like to talk
about a very different kind of network
which is a gene regulatory Network and
this is a project to try to understand
PK an a/b inhibition into tuberculosis
and so this was done in conjunction with
two groups at Children's Hospital across
the street from us and the reason for
looking at PK NAB is that PK nanp can be
are essential kinases in tuberculosis
and they've been shown to be involved in
cell shape control and cell wall
synthesis but the pathway is regulated
by by these kinases are not fully known
so what we'd like to do is actually
inhibit PK nav there's a drug for doing
that small molecule and then try to
elucidate what the downstream effects
are using a gene regulatory network
approach so what we have then are a
series of experiments in cell lines so
this is the h37rv tuberculosis cell line
and we have two compounds with what we
call t4 which is the active version of
the pka inhibitor a B inhibitor and then
a chemically an activated version of
that same inhibitor which we call t10
which is our control compound so then
what we do is perform a time course and
then collect RNA seek at 12 24 and 48
hours and we have nine samples for each
treatment time point combination and so
what we'd like to do then is actually
integrate that with publicly available
chip seek data for 143 transcription
factors that have been shipped in
tuberculosis and also protein-protein
interaction data that is also available
on the string database and so our method
for integrating all of this is a gene
reconstruction algorithm called panda
which was developed by kimberly glass
who is a former postdoc in our lab and
if you're it interested in more details
and how to use panda and really sort of
the nitty-gritty of how it works i'd
recommend going back and looking at the
talk this afternoon from my office mate
marica kuya who discusses how panda
works in some detail and also provides a
number of examples for how you can use
in human diseases as well cancer for
example but for our purposes here I'll
just briefly recap how panda works which
is that it takes interaction data so in
this case it's we're interested in
transcription factor protein-protein
interactions and then chip seek data
from 143 transcription factors in
tuberculosis and then our expression
data which is collected from our time
course that I described over here on the
left and so it produces three sort of
initial networks the chip seek data / is
a sort of initial seed as a read our
regulatory prior if you will and then
the expression data is turned into a co
regulatory Network for the genes which
is just a Pearson correlation matrix as
our initial guess for that and then the
transcription factors are the initial
guesses for their interactions
from this ppi number and so then what
panda does is it uses a message-passing
approach to ask what is the most
important regulatory network that gets
positive inputs from all three data
types and tries to get in a sort of best
representation that is most important
across all three data teams and what
panda produces is a weighted bipartite
graph so what we can do then is compare
the no degree for example from this
output where again the degree is just
the number of edges that are coming out
from a given node and these are weighted
so we can look at the transcription
factors and ask whether or not the sum
of their outgoing weights is different
and then we can also use Condor to
detect communities and calculate Korra
scores and ask whether or not there are
differences between these two things so
our first step is to look at differences
in transcription factor out degree and
again the out degree is just the sum of
the outgoing edge weights for each
transcription factor in each condition
so you sum over all the weights for a
given transcription factor in each
condition and ask how different those
two things on and what you're looking at
on the right here is the distribution of
differences for our 143 transcription
factors and you can see there is a sort
of a slight skew for a negative
difference again reminding you that t4
is our active compound and t10 is our
control just there seems to be slightly
higher out degree the transcription
factors in the control compared to the
treatment and one way to think of that
is that these sort of negative values
mean that the expression of the genes in
the regulan the transcription factor are
less correlated so there's a Depot
hearing response to this treatment of PK
nav inhibition so then we wanted to see
what were the most significant changes
in out degree so you're looking at the
transcription factors here ranked by the
magnitude of change in their out degree
and then the p-values here are
permutation key values where we've
shuffled the gene labels on the gene
expression and rerun panda completely so
we did this a thousand times we shuffled
the gene the genes and then recalculated
a new regulatory network based on those
shuffled gene labels and so this is the
empirical p-value for those they're all
less than point one impact all of them
are less than one to five with the
exception of this tenth one right here
bottom and then these let the rightmost
three columns are the log fold change in
the differential expression from the RNA
seek and the asterisk here means that
they had an FDR less than 45 and so you
can see there's a some of the genes are
different these transcription factors
are differentially expressed but not all
and so then we went and asked whether or
not these top differential turn
targeting transcription factors are
actually interesting in the context of a
PK NAB inhibition and we actually found
that the the four that have gene names
here are actually all associated with
signal transduction cell wall function
or lipid metabolism and again PK mb have
been shown to affect cell morphology and
instill well function and then RV 001
are most differentially out debris
transcription factor has actually been
shown to be a master regulator in a gene
regulatory network reconstructed from TV
looking at epoxy and so k str as well is
involved in fatty acid metabolism and
cholesterol so seems to be solo
associated lsr too has been previously
shown to be associated with cell
function and see sor is thought to
mediate oxidative stress response so all
of these seem to make sense in the
context of a disruption of the cell wall
so one of the other things that PK Navy
do is they affect the phosphorylation of
other kindnesses so as a validation of
our
top differentially out three
transcription factors we looked at
whether or not any of these
transcription factors were
differentially phosphorylated in
response to PK nav inhibition and so
what you're looking at here is the
changes in out degree for all 143
transcription factors and then those
that are labeled in red are
differentially expressed phosphopeptides
so they're differentially phosphorylated
with a log fold change greater than 25
and an FDR less than point 05 and where
you can see is that are actually our
most positive change in out degree so
the tree transcription factor who's out
degree increased the most is actually
one that is differentially
phosphorylated and the lawd pool change
for this CSO are is actually negative 1
point 8 which is one of the top
differentially phosphorylated
transcription factors that we found so
we were also interested than in whether
or not the whole class of differentially
phosphorylated transcription factors
were more likely to have a larger change
in their out degree than the rest of the
transcription factors and so we did a
permutation test to compare them the
ratio of medians so the median out
degree change and not create excuse me
for our phosphorylated transcription
factors / the median out degree for our
our transcription factors that were not
differentially phosphorylated and we saw
that the ratio of these meetings is 2.5
and then group we did a permutation
tests and found that that p value is
less than point 0 to 4 so it seems that
differentially phosphorylated
transcription factors also have
differential out to pretty which we
thought was a nice confirmation of our
our prediction from the network so given
this we wanted to look at sort of the
next level of organization up and
compare the community structure so this
is again one of the dot plots so each
dot here represents a link between the
transcription factor and a gene and the
colored links here represent
transcription factors and genes that are
in the same
community together and this is for the
t10 network and you can see that the
modularity is not as high in this gene
regulatory Network than it was for any
of the heat you kill network so it only
has modularity point 5 and it's very
similar in the t4 network as well so the
modularity there is also 0 point 495 so
they're almost the same one of the
questions that we had then is that given
that these two different networks have
here to have very similar community
structures and if you just kind of look
at these two figures for a while you can
see that there doesn't appear to be very
much changing between the two and we
were wondering then whether or not it
was community cores that were driving
this similarity so what we wanted to ask
was houssem if something is a community
core based on our core score and the t10
network is it more or less likely to
sort of change its membership in the t4
network and so when we say here PK and a
be perturbed that means that the
transcription factor changes its
community so it's no longer in if it's
in a t4 community that doesn't have the
highest overlap if it's t10 community
you say it's perturbed and so what you
can see here for the two distribution of
four scores is that those that have much
higher course lawyers are more likely to
be unperturbed than those that have
lower for schoolers are more likely to
be for term so it seems that the cores
are not being affected by this PKA and
being vision we then looked at this for
the genes as well using poor scores from
t10 and we found that the the result was
the same which is that things that are
unperturbed or more likely to have high
core scores than things that are
perturbed so it seems that this gene
regulatory network is really trying to
maintain its community structure in the
in response to this is PK Navy
inhibition uh we then tried to look at
drug specific community enrichment so we
did a
did the genes in each of the communities
an hour to an hour t4 and our t10
networks and we found that there's some
similarity between them so for example
oxidative phosphorylation shows up both
in t4 and in t-10 but one of the the new
functions that appeared in t4 that was
not in t-10 is an enrichment for
response to stress and in fact one of
the one of the differentially
phosphorylated transcription factors
that we identified was also involved in
that was located in this community and
it's a heat shock proteins do you think
it's involved in response to stress so
we did find some signal in the community
approach but it wasn't nearly as
fruitful as looking at the differential
out degree for the transcription factors
and so as a recap for the TV section we
found that differentially phosphorylated
transcription factors especially CSO are
are more likely to be differentially
targeting so have a change in their out
degree in our network model and we think
this may affect may reflect the effect
of PKA be on phosphorylation of other
proteins and we found that gene
regulatory networks don't appear to be
as highly modular as the eqtl networks
however the degree of nodes in the gene
regulatory networks seem to be much more
useful than the global degree in the
eqtl network and then finally found the
community cores both for the
transcription factors and the genes
appear to be robust to pique a navy
inhibition and so with that I'd like to
thank my collaborators my PA I John
Quackenbush mod funny and Joe Paulsen
who worked with me on the GTX eqtls
Albert young who was a postback in our
lab who did some great work on it the TV
regulatory Network and then our
collaborators at Children's Hospital on
the TV project Bob fussing and hummus
teens at your corette Michaela Hamill
and all of our collaborators are faking
Brigham and Women's who work with us on
the COPD eqtls and so with that I'd be
happy to take any questions thanks
great thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how does it
make questions you can submit questions
by typing them into the Q&A box which
can be found by clicking the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as we can our first
question is in the context of
thermodynamic cycles of cell type
differentiation and phenotypes what is
the difference between an eqtl network
and a network that is mediated by
Michael and RNA flanking sequences I
think the difference here is that I
think the difference here at the
biological level is just that we're
looking at uh sort of polymorphisms that
are disrupting binding or regulation in
some way I think at a higher level of
the the network is sort of flexible in
the sense that if it if you can
understand this as a bipartite network
and model it as such then I think there
is some similarity there although I
think that you know for the data that we
presented here we can't really speak to
the to the thermodynamics of the cell
type differentiation that would be an
interesting problem to study but I think
that we would need much sort of finer
grain experiments and better cellular
assays to to assess that if you
co-authored a paper that lends RNA
expression data to the protein state of
cells please comment on any links from
energy-dependent cycles of protein
biosynthesis and degradation to helping
longevity via the innate immune system
the physiology of reproduction and super
plural DNA alternatively do you know any
possible links from virus driven energy
left pathology
so I can't speak to any of the any sort
of virus driven energy theft what we
looked at here in tuberculosis in the
bacterial sense uh we do have protein
expression for the experimental setup
that I described earlier with this PK a
Navy inhibition well one thing that we
found that I thought was interesting is
that the RNA expression was not very
well correlated with the protein at if
you correlate a jeans RNA level in its
protein level at the same time point the
correlation the Pearson correlation is
about point two however that correlation
doubles to about point or if you look at
a time lag so if you correlate the mRNA
at twelve hours for example and the
protein expression at 24 hours you seem
much better correlations so that's I
think as much as I could speak to on a
question in the tissue-specific eqtls I
group together are there known genetic
interaction for these eqtls
you
yeah that's a great question ah there
aren't any that I know of although to be
honest we have not yet tried to look for
them I think epistatic interactions in
particular would be a really fruitful
way to go from the network modeling
perspective of that it would violate
sort of our bipartite structure but
there are lots of I think that that
would be an example of where you would
want to change your network model to
reflect what you think is going on
biologically because I think that a lot
of what's going on in these eqtls is
probably a function of epistatic
interactions and that might help explain
some of this phenotypic variance in and
the absence of it in these these jiwa
studies that we or you have three
hundred and thirty thousand individuals
there are no more questions I would like
to once again thank dr. platy for his
presentation do you have any final
comments very much for attending thank
you very much for attending thank you
for attending today's webcast will be
available for arbonne ambulate from a 12
2017 you'll receive an email from a
bird's alerting you when this webcast
would be available for replay we
encourage you to follow that
announcement to your colleagues who live
at miss today's web event see you next
time and goodbye